Woman: They all say the same thing, I'll believe it when I see it
But that's backwards
Belief comes first. Only then can you see it.
I'm asking you to use your imagination
We've got one shot at this and I need the best team
My focus right now is my daughter
Tell me and say no I'm gonna say no
Man: What we do is dangerous
Woman: I'm willing to take that risk
Man: I don't know if I am
How does that make you feel, putting your lives at that much risk?
What about your family?
All our families know what we signed up for
You ever think about mom?
You can't let her bring us down, too
Denise, open the door baby
Did we make a mistake?
We got four people whose lives depend on my judgment
I can't have you doubting me
Computer: Limit exceeded
You could be the person that discovers life on Mars
I need you here
and I don't want you to go
I'll never have the opportunity to do work this important
Woman: Imagine the responsibility the astronaut shoulder
The personal sacrifices that they've endured
Man: I need people who are going to do the hard thing
Woman: And then they strap themselves to a rocket and they risk their lives
Screaming: Mom!
Enough already!
Woman: That's five people
Fulfilling the destiny of 8 billion